welcome to the european commission's
vehicle market surveillance laboratory
located at the joint research centre in
ispra italy
the laboratory serves the european
commission in its task of organizing and
carrying out tests and inspections to
make sure that vehicles comply with
environmental and safety requirements
jrc scientists receive a vehicle and
conduct an initial verification to
ensure that it is fit for testing
they check documents carry out
diagnostics of the emissions control and
physically examine the vehicle
at this workshop experts prepare the
vehicle for real driving emissions
testing
the vehicle is equipped with a portable
emission measurement system
this equipment is a small laboratory in
itself
directly installed in the vehicle
with this procedure we can verify the
vehicle's tailpipe emissions performance
under real driving conditions
since september 2017 according to the
european real driving emissions
regulation
vehicle manufacturers are obliged to run
this type of test before introducing a
vehicle into the market
in the test cell the vehicle is
installed on a chassis dynamometer this
allows us to simulate the road load and
wind resistance encountered by a vehicle
in motion
vehicles powered by conventional engines
hybrids and fully electric motors can
all be tested here
experts can accurately control the
testing conditions
speed ambient temperature and humidity
this facility has also the capability to
simulate driving conditions
corresponding to altitudes of up to 5000
metres
from the state-of-the-art laboratory jrc
scientists can assess the environmental
performance of a vehicle over a very
wide range of operating conditions
from this room jrc scientists prepare
and monitor the testing
verify the analysis of pollutants and
calculate the environmental performance
and energy consumption of the vehicle
thanks to these laboratories the jrc
contributes to market surveillance and
ensures that eu citizens drive safe and
clean vehicles